everybody had a good fresh con today
again thank you guys so much for coming
out we really do appreciate it we have
one more presentation this evening these
are from uh two gentlemen who need
practically no introduction mr sid meier
and mr bruce shelley give him a big hand
please
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you
i would like to thank our special guest
for being here today bruce shelley
all the way from chicago
bruce and i worked together for quite a
number of years on quite a number of
games and i thought it might be fun to
kind of
talk a little bit about the story behind
how some of those games got made
some of them you may have heard of
what happens is over time
a lot of times it seems like that game
was inevitable that you know the way it
turned out was the only way it could
have possibly turned out
but uh there's a lot of twists and turns
between a game idea and the final
product and a lot of that is involved in
kind of the story behind how how it got
from a from an initial idea to the
actual product
um so i thought we might might be fun to
talk with bruce about what he remembers
about those days what i remember about
those days
uh and how some of these games kind of
came together um
might give you a little bit of an
appreciation about how how things were
different back in those days how things
maybe are still somewhat the same
uh and uh i also gave you a chance to
maybe add some questions about you know
if you had a question you always wanted
to know about how railroad tycoon came
to be or what the story behind
civilization or you know why did you do
that or whatever
so um
uh we'll get started with uh the first
game that we worked on together was
covert action
um
back in the back in the late 80s didn't
actually get published until 1990
but um bruce had come to firaxis i'm
sorry like a pros
i might do that once or twice i'm sorry
bruce had come to microprose and uh had
done some work on well i'll let him tell
the story how he how he came to mike
improve i was hired to work on uh f-19
stealth fighter i remember i worked and
i worked in baltimore for the avalon
hill game coming i was a board game
developer and designer and i decided
that the industry was going away and i
found out that the company that made
pirates was right here in the same city
i worked in so i lobbied those guys for
out for a year trying to hire them i
thought you need game people you need
game people you got one guy making games
the rest of your artists and programmers
you need more people with game
experience and finally after a year of
bugging them they did they did offer me
a job and they put me to work on f19
making maps 3d maps and
objects for the 3d game
that's how i remember and we had other
jobs too everybody who worked their
design job was managing other things
ports to other
platforms and stuff like that but my
principal job was working on f19
so
somehow i'd gotten on this covert action
project bruce actually reminded me a
short time ago that i'd seen other
couple other people working on it and i
said hey that looks like fun maybe i
should design that game
but what i remember is that they they
kind of dropped the ball they were
having trouble making it work and i
thought sid was intrigued by this idea
of procedurally generating
like uh
cases caseloads like
one of the dreams is always like a
procedural sherlock holmes game which
just generates sherlock holmes mysteries
forever and ever i know people are still
trying to do that and uh
but i think sid was intrigued by that by
that challenge and i think that's
personally looking back that's what i
think god just got him hooked
just to give you a little perspective
how many people do you think were
working at microprose at that time i
would say in development we had there
was a hallway to divide the suits from
the guys making them doing the work and
on our side it was like i would say it
was like 30 or 40 people yeah so and we
were working probably on three or four
games at that time
so things were a little different that
might have been was that in the mps labs
do you remember the mps labs
we decided that development programming
was cool and the suits as bruce refers
to them were not so cool so
we decided we were mps labs because
there was like bell labs and labs people
were really cool thank the hubble people
for coming here
so we
put a sign on the door between the the
business side of the building and the
program you are now entering the labs
mts labs and they have a photograph of
suit with his white lab coat
remember that yes i did i think i still
have that lab coat but anyways we
thought we were really cool in those
days
uh so i was working on covert action and
i i asked bruce to work with me because
he had
he was a cool guy
and um
then the story is uh that apparently i
went away on uh my summer vacation for
two weeks
and i came back with a uh prototype of
the game we actually ended up working on
which was railroad tycoon
uh
so
things were
we had this freedom i guess to just say
i don't i don't want to do that game i
really would rather do this
i did what i was told
um so i had um when i was a kid my
father and i put together a model
railroad layout
and um
i remember that
there was this track was h0 there was
his track
and you had to put these little tiny
spikes in the track and every inch of
track had probably like 10 spikes in it
and um
so
i'm not sure what my dad was doing but i
was putting in these spikes
uh for hour after hour uh to build this
glorious model railroad that we actually
never ended up finishing
uh
but
being a game designer i thought to
myself wow you know wouldn't it be cool
to be able to just make model railroad
layouts without having to put any spikes
in just tell the computer what you
wanted and they would make this cool
model railroad layout
so that was kind of the product that was
the inspiration between
before uh railroad tycoon was like
build a model railroad and um what ended
up happening was a lot of us were
playing bruce's game
1830 the uh the railroad board game
1830.
anybody remember agent actually i
it was design it was designed by a
fellow in england a famous designer an
england francis trusham and he wanted
avalon hill to publish a version of it
and uh i was the guy was
uh who who got that job so you know i
work so i i made some changes to the
game but it was basically france's
design and we played we had enjoyed
playing it it was like
it was like uh
i think one of the inspirations i think
the other inspiration was simcity come
out they had trains running around sim
city i think that caught your eye that
visual stuff caught your eye
yeah i think uh 1830 kind of
was the reason we gradually started
adding more and
it was no longer a model railroad it was
a real railroad and now you're making
money and
uh it really evolved from this very
simple uh model railroad game to
you know adding all these other features
of stock market dot stock market put in
there and robert barons
all these characters and uh
towards the end i remember um
adding the other railroads because there
was like no uh no urgency no competition
and one of the characters of 1830 is
there's a lot of kind of backstabbing
and cut throating and
competition so i uh
probably a month or two before the end i
tossed really quickly in these these
competitive railroads and they cheat
totally and they don't follow any of the
rules but they're there to kind of give
you you kind of get in your way and give
the game some sense of
competition and urgency about making
your railroad
so so part of the story i think in those
days was was trying to trying to fight
the technology and trying to get the
best out of the very limited technology
that we had at the time uh railroad
tycoon was was written on a an ibm
computer uh we had just graduated from
the days of having four callers
to now glorious days of 16 colors
and
so there's a couple screenshots here
that you can see of how how much we did
with
there's one with lots of real lots of
trains i'm out of the pc i had to work
with had a 30 kilobyte hard drive
and we we made i mean i mean i did my
job whatever i had to do on on this game
with a 30 kilobyte hard drive
and
bruce was talking a little while ago
about uh how long it took and how and
the cost of making this one of the one
of the suits i remember who he asked me
to put together some analysis of what it
cost and
to make this game because the guys down
this other hall were not too excited
about a railroad game but uh so i
analyzed i took all the people worked
and what they got paid roughly i didn't
know exactly the time and it turned out
that at the time it was just sid and
myself and max remington are artists
and uh it took about six months to make
railroad tycoon it cost the company
about 167 thousand dollars
by the time we added more people at the
end and so that looks it looks
incredibly cheap
looking back in time you can't hire a
terrific programmer for that cost for
one year today
and we tapped into
the the railroading community which was
really really they're you know
people who like railroads love railroads
and we got a ton of great feedback from
them i still remember kind of connecting
with that community the other thing i
remember is um
there was this uh
feature of of the game where your bridge
bridges could wash out and and like you
could buy a cheap wooden bridge or a
little more expensive iron bridge or
stone bridge if you bought the cheap
wooden bridge it would kind of wash out
every now and then you had to kind of
rush to stop your trains before they
would go into the river
and um
and we had this
this
philosophy that no one is ever going to
die in our game so we convinced max
remington the artist to create this
animation where these this train would
be heading for this broken bridge and
just before it got there the engineer
and the conductor would jump out and the
train would go over the edge but they
would be saved so uh
so we've kind of we tried to carry that
forward actually i remember in in
pirates there would be this scene uh
before the ship sinks all the crew jumps
off you know they're just
swim away so we had this this idea that
we didn't want anybody to die in our
game so we kind of went a little bit
overboard
uh
in trying to do that
i would say one more thing about those
bridges i thought that was a lesson that
i remember for years well i still carry
it on is that originally the bridges
would just the things would just wash
out and the player could do nothing
about it so you're you're you know you
know
you'll be building this railroad you
spend a lot of time and all of a sudden
whom there's this force of nature that
would come in and crush you and it's
like man that sucks and uh and i think
this this came up one of your your one
of your your first presentation about
game development i ever read i never
listened to you said that the player
should have the fun not the develop not
the designer and look at me like this
was a case where the program was having
the fun it was wrecking my railroad
and i couldn't do anything about it so
that's when he came up with the idea of
the bridges and you and then then the
player had an interesting choice which
is another fundamental thing about
design i think is that the player you
give the player choices so now i had a
choice i could build a cheap wood bridge
and i get my railroad running quickly
but it had the risk of washing out or i
could spend for the stone bridge and
guarantee without the washout so i
thought that to me i'd look back on that
as one of the things that i thought was
really fundamental about design the
players should have the fun
and uh i thought that was that was a
thing i remember looking for
one of our 10 rules of game design which
fluctuate over time and
but uh we that was one of the things we
did at microprose was trying uh think
about what makes games work and kind of
pass that along between the between the
designers and as bruce mentioned uh one
of the inspirations for railroad tycoon
was uh simcity and and railroad tycoon
was really the first game we did at
micro pros that had this kind of
construction
aspect to building starting small
building something of your own design
allowing you to be very creative in this
fun sandbox and that actually carried
over to some of the other games that
we'll talk about uh
in a minute um anybody have any
questions about railroad tycoon and
behind the scenes what what happened
that was kind of uh the first time bruce
and i had a chance to work together
no good okay oh sorry yes
um actually um almost every game and
that you'll see in this presentation has
been remade at least once road tycoon
not by not by us but railroad tycoon was
made remade a couple times um
and uh just to preempt any more
questions thank you for asking about
whether we're gonna remake game x
uh and i have nothing to announce at
this presentation
okay so after railroad tycoon
we came back to covert action
i i guess that was a management decision
um but um
we're still intrigued by this this idea
of the the spy case and and uh the my my
most vivid memory of covert action is
what we now call the covert action rule
which is um
don't something not to do
with pirates we had um a cool story with
some cool action sequences that we kind
of just spice it up
uh and we we kind of overdid that with
covert action there was this cool
mystery story that you were trying to
unravel
and
as part of that you would dive into
these fun
mini game sequences i think we have a
couple of them there's like the
the one where you sneak through the
building and open safes and get clues
and and toss grenades and shoot guards
and things like that
uh there's these are kind of little
games i always wanted to make like a
code breaking game you know
cracking a code or solving a
electronic circuit so these are all
really cool puzzle games and you they
would you'd get clues as you went and
did these things
um
and it was all all the pieces were
really fun but what we found was that
they that they um got in your way that
that you would be uh unraveling this
mystery and you have these clues and
you'd go into this building and
about 10 minutes later you'd come out of
the building and it was like what you
know what was that mystery i forget the
clue you know it was uh basically we
boiled it down to
two great games are not as good as one
good game and uh it's really actually
it's uh surprising how many times since
then that that kind of concept has come
into play when we talk about a game
design is you know a lot of games have a
strategic aspect and tactical aspect and
um
what we what we really got out of that
was that you have to have your center of
gravity somewhere very clearly like this
is where the game really happens in
pirates you know the the strategy part
the sailing the interacting with people
is where the majority of the game is and
you kind of go have a quick sword fight
here or a quick ship battle there but it
doesn't take you out of the flow of the
story in covert action
it's a fine game but i think it really
has this
this issue of
being hard to kind of keep in the
players uh keep the whole
story in the player's mind and uh it was
a lesson we kind of i think took took to
heart in in some of our later games
it
we we got to feature our artist max
remington uh with his unisex name so you
could be max or maxine remington i wrote
the whole manual so you couldn't tell if
the character was a man or a female
way ahead of our time
and uh i think they the uh it was a fun
game to put together in terms of the
mini games and things like that um
but maybe not as well known as some of
our other games although someone today
did ask me we know when when is covert
action two coming out
uh again i have nothing to announce
today
now in the middle of
developing covert action
i actually came to bruce one day with a
prototype of another game
which turned into civilization
some of you may
and
the the initial prototype uh and this is
kind of like a lot of the irony of
development comes into play was um
inspired by simcity
and was a real-time game it was um
uh
let's you guys go build a city here and
let's farm in this area here and you
know we'll build a mining over here and
you kind of sit back and watch all this
stuff happen
and um
what kind of worked well in simcity
felt uh you you felt really removed from
playing the game you're more watching
than you were doing
what what i call where the model is
where the computer's having all the fun
the models having all the fun
um
so we
the genesis of the game is i remember i
remember kind of being on a train with
you bruce and we said you know tycoon
was fun what's what's another topic that
we could kind of take this
start small build approach and uh
being the bold youngsters we were
the history of civilization no problem
we'll just toss that into a game you
told me once choose a big topic for your
game i'm going wow about the history you
know how can it get any bigger than this
history of
civilization i i agree that's a good
idea that might make a good game you
know
but actually that's one of our other
rules the make it epic rule i mean if
you're going to make a game why not
making about why not make it about some
some huge epic topic um
i may be laughing a years later people
making farm simulations you know
you know it's probably it could be
really interesting but i'm thinking man
this is a violation of the rules like i
couldn't i can't think about doing this
running a farm yeah come on we just
okay so i mean maybe we need to revise
that rule a little bit but
so we ended up finishing
looking at this prototype and saying
it's interesting but there's something
not right about it and you know we had
this kind of real time watching quality
to it
and so we trudged back to covert action
i guess and eventually shipped that
i don't know
i don't i don't think we worked all that
long in that game but it i remember i
remember i said i said we should change
this i'm going to make this business fun
let's do more of this and you said nope
we're finishing this game and we're
going to get onto the thing we really
want to do which is this other project
that we're not telling anybody about uh
that's true we had to be a little bit
surreptitious in those days about
we were basically inventing stuff as we
went along i think i mean we'd we'd have
an idea for a game and put a prototype
together
and
even in those days there was the idea
well we should be you know we did this
game and it was a good
you know
uh microprose was known for flight
simulators and things like that you know
why don't we should be making some more
flight simulators i think we
we had other ideas um
i couldn't land an airplane so i didn't
really want to do it quite simply
now with with civilization i remember a
couple of things that
we now had access to 256 colors
and that
was um
we didn't we couldn't guarantee there
would be toner for this was 236 but
some computers had 256 dollars now the
screen on the on the right here um
represents what we had to do in 16
colors that's the best we could do in 16
colors
um this is the athens times from
40 a.d apparently
um
lions defeat gladiators seven to nothing
so we were having you know to make fun
you have to have fun so uh just kind of
a
indication of uh how empowered we felt
to
amuse ourselves
but
the
a lot of the ideas that actually have
carried forward into
the more recent civilizations kind of
were pioneered
uh with civ one uh this is the
the palace apparently i've upgraded my
statues but i still live in a
cave cave
you got a good landscape architect but
your building guy is not doing the job
for you
the city view
i think that's elvis there in my city uh
apparently my
my happiness
i remember i remember being just totally
blown away when elvis showed up one day
you know how we're gonna keep the
population happy you know we talk about
happiness and political things and all
the things are entered into the picture
and then
how are we going to make them happy and
actually no i get a new build and
there's elvis
so maybe you want to talk a little bit
about the working
process that we had in in those days was
kind of kind of unusual yeah i mean um
it was a very strong learning experience
for me basically i have a disc a floppy
disk at home somewhere in my stuff that
says may 1990 and it's the first
copy of civilization that i ever played
and probably anybody other than sid ever
played
and you know i wrote a way i knew this
was cool and it got better and better
but the way we worked is i i was an
employee and
i get to work early
and sid was
you know a manager or a senior guy he
got in when he felt like it so but but
before he left every night he would
leave a disc in my desk and i come in
the morning and play so by the time he
arrived hours later
i'd already put in hours of play and i
had a whole list of yellow pad full of
stuff we could talk about so we would
have a couple hours of conversation
about the game and then i'd go off and
do something else i was working on
another project possibly and then before
he left he'd have a new build so this
just went on his irem call for months so
basically i'd get a new build we'd i'd
play it i'd tell him what i thought he'd
play it and think about what he was
thinking about it we would meet at some
point during the day and we discuss the
things that had changed and what was
working what was not working
or what what was missing what do we need
to add what we need to take away
and um i just remember that area of
process
being incredibly cool and
just felt totally alive with what we
were doing i thought we were
making something that's gonna be special
and
i've to everywhere i've gone since then
i've carried that whole idea this is how
we make games we prototype early and we
iterate every day play it every day and
change it every day and it's
and i i'm not i haven't seen a better
way to make a game if you can get the
guys in charge you're paying the money
let you do that take the time i don't
i've never seen a better way to make
games and it was it was just great to do
it
that's my recollection yeah i remember
thinking fairly early on that it was a
little bit special i don't i don't i
don't know exactly what it was but it
fell together in in it was kind of easy
in some ways
i've talked more recently about this
valley of despair that seems to happen
in most projects
where somewhere in the middle
things just
if you're ready to give up uh this
project didn't seem to have that is
maybe time has erased that memory but uh
but it just seemed like this game kind
of came together fairly smoothly there's
definitely some some some wrong turns
and and maybe talk a little bit about
that but but overall it felt like a a uh
the game kept getting better and better
i agree i i agree i i just remember we
we you bring up something new or i'd say
you know we you're talking how do you
keep population happy you have to feed
them you have to entertain them clothe
them so we we had all these different
parts coming together but but maybe we
didn't have them all together but
entertainment was a thing that came in
late i'm thinking well how do you
entertain people how do you entertain
people and uh you know eight three
thousand years ago 2000 years ago and we
weren't going to have gladiators i
didn't think you know
and so they're all dead i was just that
was the way i mean i just remember we'd
have these little we they were not
critical things that
caused despair it was a problem we had
to solve and solving those problems was
great it was really fun i mean sometimes
we we'd talk about it and more often
than not
i think the answer would show up on the
next disc that i got and i didn't well
we'd talk and i never knew that the
answer had been resolved the next thing
there's a build and there's an answer i
said well this is working yeah okay
what's the next problem we're going to
deal with we got that one
there's there's so much power in being a
designer and you know the the fun of
making these games is you know tossing
in genghis khan and
giving somebody nuclear weapons or you
you just feel this sense of of awesome
power and you know kind of bruce and i
would talk and and then an idea would
pop up and we'd just put it in the game
and you know like bruce says the next
day
it would be
it would be there
there's a there's a we have a museum
here i don't know if you've had a chance
to look at it but there are a couple
books there
that
i
i read
uh when i was just kind of formulating
the idea of the game and and i would
highlight
like oh bronze working yeah okay i like
that you know
gunpowder so
i almost literally translated these
books into our our tech tree
and um
and it seems so natural but
the the whole idea of a tech tree was a
new idea that we introduced and then a
lot of these
a lot of these things that went into the
game just you know you look back and say
wow that's what would the world be like
without a tech tree you know i mean
how could we live without it well i
think was great because i think both of
us had an interest in history and
and uh i like i studied economics in
graduate school i liked economic history
so it was cool to see all this
come together and actually be applicable
to making a game and and having it make
some rational sense i mean i remember
thinking like a small thing like we were
talking about technology and i thought
about i thought about the stirrup i'd
read about the stirrup being critical in
the history of warfare because a mounted
man was only worth so much when he
couldn't when without a stir but once he
had a stirrup he could anchor himself
into the stirrup and put the lance couch
the lance and he hit somebody with not
with the power of the lance but the
power of the horse a two thousand pound
horse and himself and the it was like it
revolutionized warfare for a while that
the mounted man with that serp was was
it was was the top weapon on the ward so
it was so a little thing like that
became a technology that you that you
researched and made your [ __ ] better
that was cool
to see it all come forward
another thing i remember is um just the
idea of a strategy game was um
it was kind of a a bad word in those
days like oh that's a strategy game it's
you know it was a war game yeah i was
like
got your
hexes and your units and only
hardcore
nerds play those not cool nerds like us
the hardcore
nerds would play that kind of a game and
um
the irony is that so many games are
strategic strategy is a good word these
days you know that there's real-time
strategy and turn-based strategy etc but
um
the um
it was a world where strategy was a bad
thing and you know i i'd like to feel we
played a part in turning it into to a a
you know a good thing and there was uh
there was so much that was uh
just trying stuff out in civilization i
think they know that the the scope of it
um
the um
i still remember the very first screen
with you know your your your settler
and and seven heck seven
nine squares sorry
you know and
that became this kind of iconic
beginning of something exciting you know
people came to a point where they would
look at that and say oh i wonder what
the story is going to be behind these
nine squares you know
and just to be able to start that small
and um and
create a different story every time i
think was uh was really cool and
what happened was we really didn't know
what we were doing i think but but then
we said
later it's like oh we've done something
cool what did we do and how did we do it
and how do we do it again
and that that kind of turned into trying
to analyze what was you know how where
does this one more turn come from where
does
you know what is it about this game that
we made that actually works you know
and uh
uh
you know i think we've
it's like um the familiarity of the the
the setting that the fact that you
realize that you know gunpowder is
probably going to be a handy thing to
have someday and we don't explain that
to you you see it there uh gunpowder
or you know what the the fact that the
the the world felt familiar and and
manageable and the people that you ran
into or you had built-in personalities
with you know genghis khan or gandhi
with nuclear weapons or whatever it's
like uh you know
i can identify immediately why
why i should worry about this person or
why that's funny or
you know the fact that um
it was tied into history just enough
history to make it familiar but not so
much that you had to kind of go back to
your textbooks to be able to play
i think turned out to be a really uh a
really cool
uh balance 100 years later telling
people about somebody asked us about
i'm not sure what games exactly was but
how detailed you did your research i
mean you must have been really doing a
lot of research and my answer was the
secret was we go to the children's
section of the library
because we're trying to reach a broad
audience you know and the children's
books are full of pictures we need lots
of images to show our artists what we're
trying to do and and that's a level of
history that's probably appropriate to
reach millions of players if you if you
really want to drill down
you know i think you're going to lose a
lot of your audience so the secret was
to keep your you know the history is
just we borrow the cool stuff from
history we leave with stuff we don't
need where it is
and then the manual that you created
actually filled in a lot of that i mean
it's amazing
how many people actually read the
manuals back in those days because it uh
yeah it's a lost art i mean i i remember
i came from a board game industry and we
used to put down designer notes and
historical notes and board games and i
always enjoyed reading those so it was
cool that i got a chance to write them i
mean i'm sorry that people don't do it
anymore i thought it was it was it was
part of the value added i think i mean i
read we i mean i remember some of the
games we worked on maybe here and later
that i did we always added like further
reading you know i always yeah we did
some reading you know but and so i
always like i like to add a list of
stuff that these are kind of things we
drew from if you enjoyed this
you know there's maybe you could read
more and i and it'd be gratifying years
later to get letters or even people here
today talked about how you know playing
your game changed my life and got me
interested in something that led to a
career or i remember
microsoft i worked for microsoft years
later and they talked about you get
these letters from kids
my son was a
poor student but he played some of these
games you make and now he's interested
in his stuff we're excited and microsoft
certainly and anybody said anybody who's
making games is
gratified to hear that kind of response
yeah i think one of the little dirty
little secrets that we
uh glommed on to with with games like
civilization is that
um
people don't like to be educated but
they do enjoy learning and there's a
there's kind of an interesting
difference
that uh in in games like civilization or
age of empires
you you do feel you're learning you're
getting better you're learning
strategies you're learning you know
different things and
one you know at the end of the game
you're a slightly different person
slightly better person than when you
started and and that feeling i think is
is part of the part of the crack that
that these games uh you know the games
games are
um
we're just talking about the books yep
he mentioned going to the children's
section of the of the bookstore to to do
the research my philosophy is to do the
research after you've finished your game
to justify whatever decisions you've
made in trying to make the game fun
somebody said for that
uh as i said we we took a lot of
liberties with uh with a game like
civilization and
you know it was up to brewster then
justify all the things that we've we've
done in the manual but yeah thanks so
much
but it was always fun that was paramount
i think that that also was uh kind of a
cornerstone of what we were doing is it
you know whenever it came to to going
one way or another is like what what
direction is really the most fun we can
rationalize it uh later in in the manual
or
i remember years later i was i was doing
a presentation for uh
bill gates at microsoft and he suggested
the game we were working on shouldn't
that be marketed as educational
and my view then and has never changed
is we have to edu we have to entertain
people first and they may
be intrigued to learn more but if you
don't entertain them first you're never
going to get to the next steps so and
that's why i mentioned early borrow the
stuff from history that's going to make
fun and we leave out the stuff that's
not gonna help us
the scurvy in pirates is a good example
people say why is there no scurvy in
pirates
or slavery think about it black plague
where's the black plague why is the
black plague in the game well you know
you play for well everybody one-third of
your population all dies
not fun not fun
so the technology of sieve
what i remember is
may not be all that exciting but is the
idea of overlays for the first time we
had
overlays now in the in the pc we were
limited to 640 kilobytes
plus the which included the operating
system so
basically when memory was full you were
done with your game that was basically
how you knew you were finished if you'd
filled up the memory available
it was time to ship so um
but then we discovered this cool thing
called overlays which was we would
reserve an area of memory and we could
load stuff in from the disk
and then ship it out when we didn't need
it again so sieve ended up having all
these reports because we could put those
on a separate piece of code that we
would overlay and swap in and out
and uh whereas we didn't have that on
railroad tycoon so
uh sieve ended up having uh i think the
city screen is on an overlay there a
bunch we were able to do more where
again we were kind of cut with our
ambitions were always pushing up against
the limit of the technology
and um
i i remember
feeling freed by having that
um
the
we're still limited but i think we
actually did a cga version of sieve as
well as the so we'd had a four color
version of
16 color but now the glorious world of
256 colors was open to us and we could
color cycle and make the rivers flow and
do all sorts of cool things that that we
couldn't do before still really
enlisting your imagination however and
making it all come to life
but uh you know as the technology was
advancing we were able to do some some
cooler and cooler things
um with the game
i'm thinking uh actually of some of the
things we did wrong and sieve or or
were strange um i did wrong no no me me
although we did consult daily as i
recall as you mentioned so
so for some reason i put zones of
control in to one um
i
you know if i had to do over again i
wouldn't do that
but i
i really imagined uh pretty elaborate
tactical battles happening on that map
and uh that never happened uh more the
stacks of doom that ended up being the
the way to play
but um
for some reason i was imagining i put in
zones of control so you couldn't move
from one square next to another unit
next to it so
uh at one point i had a map that was
twice as big as the the map that ended
up going into the game and i remember
slogging my way across the continent one
in one game i said all right this is not
working out this has to be and and that
that's actually another rule that that
that more is not always uh better
um
there was a there was a second tech tree
in there at one point that we that that
we took out
and um
the controversy about squares versus
hexes is
to me still kind of interesting
that um
all of us who had kind of grown up in
the board game world you know love texas
because they're so
uh
they don't have diagonals you know we
hate diagonals and and uh but when we
propose this game
we just did not want to be labeled as a
geeky uber nerdy strategy so we knew if
there were hexes in there that people
would would freak out
so uh we made the game about squares and
we dealt with the
evil diagonals
and the irony is of course you know a
few few iterations later it was safe to
put hexes into sieve
and now we now we embrace the hex
but um you know
just uh kind of interesting however over
uh over time
uh
things evolve and again the world is now
safe for for strategy
the other thing that struck me about the
original sieve was um
that introduction with the music by jeff
briggs and um
in the beginning the earth was without
form and void it's like
okay
um
we're
we're going to do something here you
know i really felt it was important to
set the stage
um this is maybe
different from any other game that you
have played before we're we're um
we're not ashamed of our ambitions you
know it's kind of like
this is the history of the world from
the very beginning until you come and
take over and create this this you know
to the present day and even perhaps a
little bit into the future
um
there was kind of a
boldness uh
perhaps um based on our our youth at the
time that we were kind of willing to
make that statement i i
and then you know i asked the artist to
make this these cool
pictures of the earth evolving and you
know
i felt uh
i'm not sure what had been done before
that in terms of introduction but i
thought you know we were kind of making
a statement in terms of that beginning
that uh you know kind of set the tone
for
those nine heck those night squares
showing up at the very beginning
uh anyways that i was i was kind of that
was a fun part of the game for me to uh
to to create
any other mistakes that you recall or
mistakes well there's an embarrassment
that i i've always been embarrassed by
the fact that you run out of technology
in age one and civilization one i'm
sorry you know like
you know you kept getting these tech
knots like the stirrup i mentioned and
steel or something else and then after a
while you start building the spaceship
to go to alpha centauri but the
technology just says something cool
happens here another technology comes
along here you know it's going great and
i thought man this is this is
embarrassing we couldn't think of any
this cell phone was not even around
future technology number seven yeah it
was a cell phone and we couldn't think
of the name so next time i did a game
anything like this i mean we're going to
have plenty of technology and you're not
going to be able to get through the list
you can't get all the technologies in
this game next game i worked on it
i thought that was embarrassing
it was hard to figure out how to end the
game i remember that like were i think
at one point we had another iteration of
units that you could evolve and then
future technology was just a little
further down the road and uh it was it
was it was a game that didn't want to
end
and um we we came up with the the
journey to al centauri and uh
a couple of other things
but um
that's one of the challenges i think
that's kind of one of the challenges
still still is that you know
going all the way from that one unit to
to the end game and making sure
everything is kind of uh
really works along the way
um let me open that up for a minute or
for a little bit and see if any any
questions about kind of the evolution of
sieve and how it came to be yes over
thank you pete
on the move pete let's hear it for pete
the other face of faraxis for a lot of
us um you know we see these awesome
images and i get to get very nostalgic
for living this and playing as growing
up do you guys get nostalgic about these
games like in that way or are you always
picking apart going man that elvis god
why did he put his hand up here it
should be over there do you i mean like
covert action do you get nostalgic or is
it just like oh too many mini games
i i do for me enough time has gone by
but i remember the good times and and
and not some of the other times i mean
when i when i saw that gladiators versus
uh
lying seven to nothing you know the
other day when i was grabbing the image
i i laughed out loud you know i was like
oh man we were having a good time uh and
um you know so i i do i have really fond
memories of that of that time and to you
know to see
that screen with the 20 different trains
on it you know
i kind of remember how much fun it was
to put that all together so uh i
definitely feel there's a warm spot you
know in my heart for the for these games
certainly yeah i feel the same way i
mean it's like i tell people you know i
got a chance to play for a championship
team
you just don't forget it
other questions
yeah when i saw these old screenshots of
civilization um i think and especially
the essen athens times from 40 80. i
think there was a lot of humor in those
games back then and uh i think that has
kind of disappeared a bit did it
disappear with you not taking an active
seat anymore in in developing the games
or where did the humor go
well i to me
we could not create realistic images we
could not create a realistic game so
that made humor
a way to do something special with the
game you know it was i think if it's
ultra realistic then you don't expect
humor but
this was kind of you know 16 colors was
all we had here so to uh
and we're trying to create fun you know
uh
uh
and if if we are not having fun a lot of
times you know it's not going to show
through if we are having fun hopefully
that'll uh encourage fun in the player
but um
the other thing i think is we're we're
calling this game civilization and
that's kind of a scary name you know and
we are inviting you to control
us uh
thousands hundreds of millions of people
through
six thousand years of history with with
um
armies and you know that could be pretty
daunting so this is a little a little
wink at the player that you know we're
on your side we're gonna we're we're
here for you we're gonna make it fun for
you to play so i think um
we did try to put some humor in in games
whether it's the evil spaniard guy and
pirates or you know the
uh these kind of overdrawn uh james
bondi characters and discovered actually
you know it's kind of like
we we we get it we're here we're both
here to have fun you know we're working
we're doing this together let's let's
enjoy it i think it was kind of part i
think what we're trying to say there
and bruce is a funny guy so he
encourages encourage that not just eye
candy
all right so you mentioned that uh you
were trying to kind of keep a covert
action to that you were developing this
you had to keep it on the down low for a
little while how far into it were you
when you finally had to come clean and
tell the suits what you were working on
and what was the response
i'm trying to remember
i think we worked for
somewhat a little under a year but maybe
a year on this game that was that
bruce was a producer so he shouldn't
know all this stuff
um
i kind of remember there was another
game that was being maybe that was we
did we did well i don't remember now
i'm getting old but we did railroad take
home for a month and i was forbidden for
working on it because the suits didn't
like it
and then and then we went back and i had
to work on covert action or all those
other things but that made me work on
covert action but and then you know i i
tell you i don't remember when the
civilization bubbled up and how long it
was for along
um because
i didn't want anybody else to play it or
you're the only person allowed to play
exactly
well
this is another memory i have is like uh
when he would give me a disc he wouldn't
let anybody else play it i was the only
one allowed to play it so um i mean i
have a crowd in my office some days you
know they say okay what's he done now
and uh
and then tell me about this and what's
going on here and i'm going will you
guys be quiet
i'm working here you know
and uh you know i'm not really sure you
know we've talked about we don't
remember exactly what it was but i think
what it was was that
he trusted me as every man average guy
average gamer and uh and and i could and
we could communicate well and if he had
if he gave it to everybody that there'd
be he'd be inundated with a thousand
ideas and he was content that i was
i wasn't threatening to be the top game
designer in a company i was a guy that
he could work with you know i was i
wasn't going to threaten him
at the top there so i'm not sure that's
true but but basically just
he did he wanted to filter the news and
uh i think both of us now in retrospect
think that that was probably not a good
idea i mean i know that i believe you
should get as many eyeballs on your
product early as you can especially
people you trust and everywhere i've
worked since we've it's been a it's been
it's been a requirement that everybody
on the project play the project daily if
not weekly if not daily and so i think
that maybe
maybe some of the things that weren't we
could have done better in the first game
sid one could have been fixed with
having more people trying it earlier on
and if we had more time to do it and
whatever i don't know but
i mean there wouldn't have been a need
for
two or three yeah that's true
i think we did a good job of not making
it perfect you know because
because you've been milking that cow
just to follow up on not exactly that
there's an interesting phenomenon the
sieve designer burnout
that everyone who designed a civ game
uh
is not at all interested in designing
the next game
and there's something about making a
sieve game that kind of you know
burns you out so i mean it seems right
it seems reasonable to me because like
there was a lot of excellent things in
here and certainly brian and jeff did an
excellent job with too then i think the
guys who had the real because you know
we we you know we we did we did things
that were not great you know the first
division to me i mean there was a lot
you know people figured out how to break
the game right away and and uh there was
other things that we could have had more
technology possibly you know so so there
was some i mean
so there was civ 2 was like like
there was a lot of things that were
could be improved but making
building on sieve too
you know i think it got much harder the
the
the barriers got harder to make to do
better thing i mean i i'm glad i didn't
have that job
well bruce you know we didn't have day
zero patches or things like that back in
the day put on
metrics
and that was the game you know we did we
have testers i don't remember i was the
tester
so it's your fault
yeah i take blame yeah dump it on me
i got big shoulders
ah other questions
hi uh just said what what would be your
favorite civ game that you've worked on
i know you
enjoyed a lot of them but what would you
say is the one you've enjoyed the most
designing
well um
that's an interesting question i i think
of them all as all the games that i've
made as different children as my
children you know and if you have
children
there's no favorite there's like the
smart one you know and the funny one and
the cute one and and i think the games
are different in that way that there's a
game that i you know i remember
we had a lot of fun making this game or
this game is pretty intense you know
this game has got a lot of intellectual
heft to it
um
but
they were all games that um that i
wanted to make and look forward to
making and and they're fun to make and
there's another 20 that i wanted to make
and haven't made yet and they're still
sitting on our hard drive but um
but i can't choose
a favorite for for me they're all
they're all fun now talking to people
you know certainly games like
civilization
pirates railroad tycoon are the ones
that they come back and say you know
i still remember playing that game or
when are you going to make another one
or you know i think those are the games
that seem to have resonated the most but
i had a lot of fun making you know
covert action or cpu box or whatever you
know whatever whatever it was it the the
the process of making games in itself is
is very rewarding so i have these kind
of fond memories of all my little
children
out there
one more one more
uh i was just thinking about a railroad
tycoon question which i forgot to answer
the forecast the first time um i
remember when playing it i've learned a
lot of geography geography from railroad
tycoon actually um i never understood to
the cities this is a technical question
did the cities grow
whether you built railroads into them or
not was that model for the city growth
related to whether you were there you
know i actually kind of remember the
answer to that question
they grow somewhat but uh the more more
the stuff that's delivered there the
faster they'll grow
but yeah i mean you're you're right that
the idea of putting the entire eastern
united states
uh represented by little tiny pixels um
was pretty bold and it's in in its day
and the fact that it would grow over
time based on what you did
was revolutionary thank you thank you
so what was how did you break the news
or what was the response to the suits
when you told them you spent a year time
developing sev
well i don't think it was a total secret
but as bruce mentioned they hadn't
actually gotten to play it
and i think that might have actually
wetted their anticipation and appetite
you know
uh i i still remember getting a call
from um from bill staley
and
times were very different then uh so we
shipped civ
and
into a vacuum i mean in those days you
would release a game and
we'd shake each other's hand and we'd
do something else
there was no internet there was no
feedback you know you get a trickle of
letters back after a couple weeks and
for siv they had this almost they almost
form letter
it was like
dear you know dearest and bruce um i
liked your game civilization i had a
great time playing it was a lot of fun
by the way here are the things that i
would change about it
thank you very much
so we started uh we started to get this
kind of feedback which um
by the volume and the and the intensity
of the suggestions that were in there we
kind of got this the idea that something
was happening
and um a couple i think two or three
months after the game went out i got a
call from from bill staley who was the
president of microprose he was at a
conference or convention somewhere and
he said sid people are talking about
your game i think it's going to be good
you know
i'm happy to hear that oh thank you bill
uh
so it really took i would say months
before we got any sort of uh indication
that you know people were playing and
responding to it and and it was really
through uh
through letters and and of course you
know the magazines would come out
monthly with the three-month lead time
or whatever so there's very little
feedback you know the kind of
instantaneous feedback that we have
today so it took quite a while before we
realized we were kind of onto something
there i think i mean i felt we were
making something special you know and i
think as more and more people at the
company got involved and and everybody
got to play in the testing i thought the
company
everybody who worked there certainly on
the development side had a very very
positive attitude this game was going to
be awesome and i thought we were making
something special was going to rock the
game world whether they knew it or not
it might take them months but they were
it was going to rock the world i really
felt positive about it and i remember
one of my friends uh glenn drover who
was a sales guy but he's he's he's
always wanted to be a game designer he's
actually doing now he would come back
and bug me all the time he'd be in town
for a salesman he says okay what is this
game all about what's happening now
what's he changed what's new and i i
know he was super enthusiastic so i i
and and i trusted glenn's instincts and
uh
i i felt that it was just it was a
sleeping bomb was going to go off in the
game industry these people i don't know
okay we released it this day maybe it
was going to take months but when we're
off it was going to go off and people
are going to really like it
i had a really positive view about it
one of the things i always hear um you
say about the good old days and one of
the things i always um garner is like
the fact that like designers had a much
more tangible tangible personal approach
in the product of the game
now i heard a rumor or something that in
civ 3 that there's like you know there's
a lovely finale of a hiding piano sonata
and as an avid lover of music i was
wondering if you were playing that or if
there's like any um
any other like little personal touches
in these civilians that um not not many
of us know about
um
there was a screenshot that came up a
minute ago from sieve where the science
advisor is handing out some lovely
technology
the artists were having fun by you know
i think they have put me into quite a
few of our our games i guess
uh so that's a little fun touch um
there's a really cool uh credit screen
in railroad tycoon where
bruce is wearing a railroad hat and i'm
in a suit or something and
since we only had like five people max
working on the game we could you know we
could have fun with it with that um
we didn't do a lot with uh with easter
eggs because
we weren't artists
plus
to sense maybe we because we were front
and center and talking about this game
and
that the the artist the easter eggs came
from the art groups as i recall because
it was one of their ways to personalize
their their work on the project
we were already all over it you know in
many ways you know it was sort of like
our
our our baby but they could they could
do something i remember like one you
know they they could sign the game their
own way secretly
it came later i think
yeah for me there's also a little bit of
us
a style that we enjoyed i mean the other
screen here greetings from our most wise
queen elizabeth of the english our words
are back with nuclear web you know i
mean just kind of going a little bit
over the top in terms of the intensity
and and the kind of fun of the game i
think was was was our little easter egg
to the player i think
thank you speaking of older games how do
you feel about sites that uh specialize
in selling older games like gog.com good
old games
i guess we're in favor of that
yeah i think they're
these games uh
the striking thing to me i think is how
much the technology has changed and how
little kind of the essence of game
design has has changed that
some of these ideas that uh we expressed
like 25 years ago
still kind of hold up today
um
so you know having the opportunity to to
play some of those older games i think
is certainly a good thing but um
you know the fact that bruce and i are
still making games
um even though we don't necessarily code
in the latest style or understand the
latest technology we have a feeling for
game design i think that that still
works today so to be able to see
uh and play some of these original games
um yeah i think is is a good thing uh we
were talking a little earlier about how
um
in a lot of way you know we did a
flight simulator game and one of the
first submarine simulations and pirates
was one of the first open world games in
part civilization was um you know kind
of established a bit of a genre in terms
of strategy and forex etc
a lot of these games you know a lot of
times it's interesting to see what what
was the first game you know where where
did this whole genre start from and
that's certainly where it gives you an
opportunity to to do that
i remember like talking old games a game
called empire deluxe and we didn't
mention that but i think it was one of
the influences when we were making these
games i remember i was talking today to
say it about remember when you gave me
the task we've been playing empire
deluxe and he said come up with 10
things that you would change about
empire deluxe if you could and that was
some of the stuff we thought about
persiv and i remember i was i was i felt
always a new guy on the in the job and i
wanted to make a big impression so i
came up with 12 things
yes i think you've managed to all but
answer the question i had which was uh
your games are famous for being the one
more turn kind of addictive nature games
and i was wondering what particular
inspirations you had to draw upon
that
there were
probably three games that i remember
very well um
empire
uh which had this revealing the map
quality to it which was uh became you
know one of the fundamentals of
civilization but
um you know you'd be playing and all of
a sudden the unit would show up on the
edge of your uh you know what you could
see
oh what's going on over there i better
you know then that would gradually
reveal itself so i think that
the exploration aspect of sieve was
inspired quite a bit by uh by empire um
simcity uh i think all of us were
playing that at the time and
just that change in focus from let's
blow everything up you know as quickly
as possible with explosions as large as
possible
uh to let's build something let's have
you know here's a nice little space
let's make something here
uh that that inspired uh i think part of
railroad tycoon and certainly was
something that we uh we carried forward
um into civilization and uh in in an
interesting way railroad tycoon kind of
inspired uh civilization because
um
we were able to make uh you know what's
now called a god game or you know we
were able to to
to make these systems that um that are
that interact to create an interesting
game i think that's kind of the heart of
civ to me is
these uh simple systems uh you know the
the feed your people and they will grow
uh
you know build a city and it will make
stuff uh talk to other leaders
if you have a bigger unit than they have
you will win um the the individual
systems are are very
comprehensible and easy to understand
but the way they interact with each
other and the way you need to trade them
off makes each game different and
creates um
we call kind of interesting complexity
and railroad tycoon kind of explored
that with operating a railroad and
financing a railroad and buying and
selling stock and competing with other
railroads it was kind of like a bunch of
stuff going on but the way it all worked
together was was cool so that that idea
of of being able to have a number of
interesting systems in the same game at
the same time
have them uh have them really work
together to create all sorts of things
to think about kind of led to that one
more turn you know you've always got
uh something building and something to
explore and and you know so those to me
those three things kind of um together
with just the epicness of the topic
you know stirred together kind of were
what turned out to be civilization
i guess we have time for one more
question yeah could a game like this be
made today something that's so far
outside of what's proven of like the
flight simulators that you're supposed
to do or are things just too expensive
and too
codified now in our uh different genres
that's a great question i think it's
very hard to get visibility these days i
mean there's so um there were only there
weren't that many games out when we put
out civilization if you wanted to play a
game you know what if you randomly went
into a store close your eyes and grab
something you might grab civilization um
so it was a it was a it was a different
time i think that the challenge today is
is even if you have a really cool unique
game how do you get
how do you get it out there how do you
get people to know about it um
so i think um
uh the other the other question the
other issue is the development cost i
mean are you if you're trying to make a
aaa game
you know i don't know what the how much
it cost us to make civilization but it's
probably
certainly um just a couple hundred
thousand dollars you know today it's
millions and millions so it's hard to be
as adventurous risking that kind of
money so
uh on the other hand i think it's a
great you know we're still in a golden
age of of games when you look at the
cool titles that are out there both in
the aaa space and also the indie and the
mobile and all you know whatever kind of
game you want to play you can probably
find it that's that's the good news in
our days you know if you want to play
strategy game you pretty much had to
play civilization or sim city you know
those were your choices
i would say i would say that uh i've
i've thought about this too and that
all over i've been making games now
professionally as a living for like 35
years and i think there's always been
what i call a platform frontier a
frontier platform where somebody a small
team could do something significant no
matter you know how and all that time
period so my case example is this fella
in vietnam a couple years ago and made
flappy birds or something like that i
mean by himself here's a guy in korea
who made a game out of nowhere that was
making i don't know what was making 30
40 50 000 a a day or something like that
something's crazy so
despite the fact that there's you can
spend
200 million dollars making a game here's
a fella
off the beaten path in uh in korea who
made a game or vietnam i guess it was
who made a game that really rocked the
world changed a little changed a little
bit so i think it's i'm not giving up
the idea that there's somebody small
team or some individual can't do
something really special
i think that's going to be the case for
forever
thank you very much appreciate your
interest and
so
we don't really want it to come to an
end quite yet so what we're going to do
is we're going to have our raffle now
real quick we're going to have sid and
bruce draw some uh some numbers
you